let's play three minute game
it's another bait norwegian
with from my uh he has the avatar from
my favorite
norwegian football club stomach which is
surely
it's an effort to to bait me into
playing him but
in that case well done
um e3
yeah we see sort of a color system for
white here
which is very solid b3 i'm going to take
d4
ed4 i was kind of happy to see that
because now we get
now we get a fixed pawn structure
in which you know
black is usually very much fine like i
don't think you would particularly mind
playing this position with the colors
reversed
so i would say objectively speaking
black is probably
a little bit better already and playing
ct5
provoked i'm sorry unprovoked i would
say
is a bit of a positional positional
mistake
um since with
with those pawns on c4 and d5
if i do decide to take on
if i do decide to take on um oh this is
a bit tricky
if i go a6 there is uh
okay i'm just gonna go 97 keep it simple
so what i was going to say is if i do
decide to take on c4 at some point
either white gets knight c4 um
with with tempo or you can go bc4 and
create hanging pawns
in the center and i think both of those
scenarios
scenarios are better for white than just
taking a d5 immediately
but i gotta say that my opponent is
playing very well
after he took on d5 he's gone
for bishop b5 um gun knight c495 and
he's gained
uh a bunch of activities for his pieces
um that can sort of
make up for the
the slight weaknesses of his structure
rookie one
this one i'm not that convinced about
though
okay let me take on c1 first
because i'm really attracted to
queen c1 bishop e5 here
if knight e5 i got knight g2
it is a little bit suspicious maybe um
but i think it works knight g2 i mean
i'm always a little bit worried about
some d5 coming some knight g4
with mate threats and so on but i think
it should have worked out for
for black and now with the bishop on c1
um
obviously knight e5 knight g4 could not
be as dangerous as the bishop would not
be on the
on the a1 h8 diagonal um
aiding mate uh aiding a possible mate
there
and this was my point that
i had this little trick um of taking on
d1
after de and then knight d3
as far as i can see winning an exchange
and most probably
the game uh there's bishop h6
oh wait a sec this is complicated
bishop h6 knight e1
okay it's not that complicated
i got bishop f3 so thinking of knight f3
then
bishop f3 and he's threatening both e7
and b7 but i go bishop
f3 and now if bishop b 7 there's not
bishop d1 remaining a piece
up uh and gf3 king f8
would also have been a piece up and
although my pieces are a
bit funnily placed here there's nothing
you can do about it
and they're gonna they're gonna escape
with um
the result of me being uh
fairly clean piece up i'm just gonna go
knight e4
it's gonna take on p5 go b4 i suspect
that knight c6 picks up the pawn on
on on b4 okay let me just
go bishop b3 he has queen king d2 now
take on b4 because the king c3 attacking
both
pieces but i got bishop d5 attacking g2
so i do win
one of his pawns after all h4 i'm just
gonna go
h6 king h7
he's fighting extremely well i have to
say okay then he resigned but
he was fighting well keeping my king in
a bit of a cage
next i would have gone g5 though if fg i
go h5
then bring the king to g6 f5 pick up e5
or if hg i go h5 and then the h1 just
runs
and besides of course i'm a piece up so
it's all it's all fine